I'm from England or Australia you guys
don't seem to give a crap I just turned
32 I'm already jealous of young people
I'm improper young people children
children today are living the childhood
I dreamt of okay they want to hear a
song touched they stream it they've got
it now bang instantly they don't know
the pain of LimeWire start downloading a
song go to school come back hope that it
had finished that download bar messing
with you
four minutes left 9 hours and 28 minutes
left 20 seconds left 52 hours and 30
minutes left
just tell me the truth this is before
downloading music was legal you could go
to jail what are you in here for murder
you
possession of heroin you downloading
limp Biskit rollin
this was a time not only did you have to
hope that the song you were downloading
would eventually complete downloading
you had to hope that that song was the
song you intended I'm downloading
imagine that now on iTunes
the latest ed Sheeran single click on it
to get a video of a horse pissing on a
man we don't appreciate when something's
finished downloading anymore
we don't we take you for granted we've
seen that buffering now and like come on
hurry up
I've got nothing to do soon I remember
the first time I downloaded a film took
a week because my mum needed to use the
phone we download an x-men - x-men - on
the family computer to release the huge
family computer willing to turn up the
speaker was down the back of the desk
you have to climb over sat in your
wheelie chair best friend sat next to me
on the laundry basket
we download an x-men to sit there after
seven days complete 20th Century Fox
comes up no pixels no shaky cam no
silhouettes of heads at the bottom of
the screen people coming in five minutes
late none of that we thought we'd done
it this was incredible we weren't gonna
have to go to the cinema we weren't
gonna have to wait for the film to come
out on video we weren't gonna have to
walk to Blockbuster young people they
don't even know what there is anymore
you have to explain it words blockbuster
basically it's like Netflix except you
can't watch the new release because
someone else in your neighborhood is
already watching it
[Music]
so we look at the screen we're thinking
please please please please be expanded
20th Century Fox fades x-men 2 comes up
we've done it we're not taking you for
granted
we're actually hugging yes we look at
the screen Wolverine turns around she is
gonna come on that here but we talk
about the Bellas over there
very much later on Openshaw wolves
you